Zack Snyder created this camera rig to
hold three separate film cameras to
capture the exact same take all at once
what if we just like film on three
different iPhones because I want to have
my own freaking Snyder cam sequence
action
this is
so the movie 300 came out when I was a
senior in high school and this movie was
like a teenage boy's Dream movie it had
all the coolest stuff it had cool action
it had ABS it had slow-mo it had slow-mo
ABS I'm not I'm not obsessed with abs
but there were so many it's there were
there were at least 1800 ABS in that
movie as a skinny teenage boy I was
jealous but also just totally inspired
by the incredible action of that movie
there's this one scene in particular
that was incredible and so iconic it has
stuck with me ever since
it's the shot where the camera is like
flying sideways tracking the action as
we're seeing the Spartans just lay waste
to all the Persians and you see King
Leonidas right there in the center all
buffed with a shield and sword and spear
just like going to town but the iconic
part of this moment was the speed
ramping and the Crash zooms and this was
achieved with a very unique camera rig
Zack Snyder and his cinematographer
Larry Fong created this camera rig to
hold three separate film cameras with
three separate lenses each at a
different focal length one with kind of
a wide angle lens one with a medium zoom
lens and then one with a pretty dang
telephoto lens there and so that way
they were able to actually capture the
same take all at the same time with
different cameras and that was why the
action in that scene from 300 was so
incredible actually using three separate
cameras to capture the exact same take
so that you can actually go in and out
between all the different focal lengths
so you can really punch in on what's
interesting or go wide to see the whole
scene all in slow-mo if you want it or
real time if you want it you can make
those choices later and that gives you
the flexibility to make sure that the
final sequence is as cool as possible it
was really novel idea at the time but
now almost 16 years after 300 was
released we have camera Tech that allows
us to replicate this effect without
three massive film cameras and a giant
crew more specifically iPhone 13 Pros
that have three separate cameras and
three separate lenses at three separate
focal lengths a lot like how they shot
that scene in 300 so I was thinking what
if we just like film on each of these
cameras because I want to have my own
freaking Snyder cam sequence I want to
have my own punch zooms and timer
mapping the way I see it there are two
paths forward using the latest iPhones
to recreate this Effect one path is to
literally take three different iPhones
each rolling slow-mo on one separate
lens and combine those together after
the fact the problem there is that we
actually would need to then design a rig
to hold those phones in a very specific
position to get those lenses as close
together as possible the easier solution
is to literally just film all three
videos on one phone and there is an app
that lets me do that it's called
multicam Pro and this will actually
allow me to record all three camera
angles at the same time the problem is
that it is limited to 1080p 30 frames
per second which means that there is no
slow-mo capabilities and for this effect
to work I really need that slow motion
but at least this will allow me to test
the stacking portion of this effect so
while I test that I have tasked Natalie
with coming up with an actual 3D design
that we can print to hold those phones
together so that we can actually do the
slo-mo portion of this effect so we're
actually walking down both paths at the
same time
[Laughter]
so Ren tasked me with building this Zack
Snyder rig so we can shoot those oily
boys the difficulty in making this rig
is that the lenses have to be stacked at
least vertically as close to each other
as possible they can't have any
horizontal shift because then you're
introducing something called Parallax
where if a camera is just slightly off
center from another camera then they're
not going to align by matters of feet
for like every millimeter I've actually
done a simple test of just stacking
three iPhones on top of each other and
seeing if that works and it does work
but this is a little bit more elegant of
a solution so the design philosophy is
just to hold the phones in the most
economical manner possible while not
obstructing the lenses this is all Made
Simple by basically mocking it up in 3D
before we ever start building it and
then I can just go in with a
dimensionally accurate iPhone model and
build around it and so I just made a
little side to side clamp that kind of
just holds it down pressure this is a
solid V1 so I'm actually busy making
props for our season two of son of a
dungeon so I'm going to pass off this
design to Ren who's going to improve it
considerably
so here's the results of that experiment
shooting Nico out in the studio and
layering those shots together it's uh
very evident which layer is which
there's a little bit of jiggle between
each of these cameras the reason being
is that our iPhones actually have little
Optical stabilizers inside the lenses
themselves so they're physically moving
to counteract the motion of your hand
and that's doing it independently
between each of these cameras what that
means is that there's now extra motion
introduced into each of these shots it's
very subtle but you can totally see it
especially between the wide angle lens
and the main lens here so of course the
whole purpose behind all of this is to
be able to get those crash Zooms in and
pulling out to the wide going to a
medium and that's what we're doing here
inside each of these little smash zooms
I'm actually keyframing the opacity of
each shot a little bit that's able to
hide the transition a little bit so when
we're viewing the wide video here we're
only looking at the wide we're not
looking at a composite of all three but
when we zoom in we're now looking at the
zoomed in shot and same thing when we go
to the medium shot here and I'm hiding
that transition
with the motion blur so this is a cool
proof of concept and it totally works
but of course this entire thing is
mostly just an exercise because we can't
use it because it doesn't shoot slow-mo
the iPhone can actually shoot 240 frames
per second at 1080p but it can't do that
with all three cameras at the same time
which brings us back to designing a rig
that holds three phones
huge thanks to today's sponsor
expressvpn for sponsoring this episode
and just like Ren is juggling three
iPhones right now I am juggling three
baseballs to give you guys a sense of
what he's going through probably
emotionally if there's one thing that
you're gonna need in a 21st century
internet world it's gonna be a VPN and
why is that well when you send your data
out on the open internet it is
vulnerable to hackers and to be stolen
and sold to third-party advertisers you
see a VPN gives you the ability to
further encrypt your data as it's out on
the open internet floating around that
means it's less vulnerable to being
taken stolen sold to third parties and
we got to keep I gotta do this all in
one take man
first take first try the best part about
using a VPN is that the best
why is this so tiring
first take first try expressvpn has
servers in over 94 countries they're
available on every device and from any
of those devices you can tell websites
that you are accessing the internet from
an entirely different location so this
feature allows you to access content
that might not otherwise be available in
your country or region now what do I
like to get into well did you know that
the entire Studio Ghibli library is
available in other countries on Netflix
they won't tell you that in American
Netflix but it actually is true it's
available so if you just tell expressvpn
that you're accessing the internet from
a different country or region you can
actually get access to the entirety of
Studio Ghibli and it's pretty cool and
listen if you don't believe me
shoot first take first try expressvpn
was rated number one VPN service by
Forbes and tech radar so if you guys are
interested in getting started today head
on over to tonight burp I'm going to
leave the burp in there head on over to
expressvpn.com Corridor crew to get
started and now
sign up right now using the link in the
description below and you can get three
months free that's
e-x-p-r-e-s-svpn.com Corridor crew all
right once again huge thanks to them for
sponsoring and now let's see what
happens with this rig
good
okay just edit out all the parts where I
drop it and we should be good to go cool
all right cool man
okay uh this is the design that Natalie
came up with here and it's very
straightforward it essentially lines up
the lenses of each camera vertically and
it has a very solid form factor here but
there's a problem with the design and
that's it's not easy to get the phones
in and out and that's kind of a an
important piece here because if we're
going to be using someone's phone they
need to have the ability to get that
phone back like in half a second another
problem that I'm seeing is that like
let's say we get them all in there how
are we going to roll the camera because
it's like on my phone here I can just
you know hit that button and great but
how am I to do that on the other cameras
the camera button itself is uh blocked
yeah okay so that is an issue this is
why we iterate on designs so that way we
can learn from how a design is working
make those adjustments and do it again
since Natalie is now working on a
different project I I went ahead and I
actually just designed honestly a
completely new design for this so the
red is the zoom lens the green is the
main 1X lens and the blue is the wide
lens and I put the blue up front because
it's going to see a whole lot it should
be the furthest thing out the zoom lens
I put in the back here behind everything
because it's field of view is really
narrow I can have the other phones
pretty much sitting right on top of it
and they won't show up in the shot my
hope is that since these two lenses are
kind of like more narrow they're
vertically aligned and so we won't see
any of that left and right Parallax
whereas the wide camera because it's so
wide you're not going to notice The
Parallax as much going off to the left
and right and I'm utilizing the magsafe
technology built into the newer iPhones
[Music]
yeah [ __ ]
magnets oh and it's like it's got some
some heft to it it's not the strongest
thing but like it'll stick I decided to
go ahead and I bought these little
magnetic rings that specifically work
with the mag safe It lines up perfectly
with the phone because it's got these
little two things down here to orient
the phone
just like that and so this way I know
that the phone will be in the exact
orientation and position I need it to be
in but I can also just take it out when
I need it as a safety precaution I might
end up throwing a rubber band on each of
these so a rubber band not exactly an
elegant solution but it works so what is
Elegance anyway
I don't know I'm I'm fairly pleased with
this design I like the Aesthetics of it
I think it's kind of cool looking so the
next step is to finish this and print
that out I'm going to do that tonight
it worked check this out I'm actually
very happy about this it is always like
so incredibly satisfying when you 3D
print something that you actually
modeled and it works so the next step in
this is to test whether or not my
magnets
even fit
then they're too big dang it I've made
the little inset here too small
fortunately this is really easy to fix
unfortunately that means a whole other
day because this is a 12 hour print but
despite that I'm like really pleased
this should work next thing you'll see
is tomorrow when this is hopefully done
again
it worked I think I don't exactly know
yet I made the changes I reprinted it
and it worked with the exception of the
fact that the printer is essentially
dead right now we can repair it I had
this issue where the print became
dislodged from the bed as it was still
printing pretty early on and that got
stuck to the printer head which didn't
know that it had failed so I kept
continuing to extrude plastic but it was
stuck on the thing and it just kind of
kept turning into this Big Blob that
expanded outwards and started engulfing
the entire printer extruder and ripped
out the temperature sensors so now I
can't even turn it back on to heat it up
to take the plastic off that put me in
an awkward situation where you know we
have other stuff needing these printers
and we're down a printer and this is a
13 hour print this has to work if this
fails again and kills our second printer
we're out uh and then we kind of have to
scrap this whole video This Is The
Moment of Truth so I'm going to take
this magsafe sticker I'm going to apply
it to the print and I'm going to see if
my phone will stick to it
[Music]
okay
strength test
foreign
oh dude look at that nothing in frame
nothing in frame hey Carmichael
you're pretty
So the plan now is to borrow a couple
phones and see if we can actually put
this whole thing together
[Music]
oh Jesus Christ
we good we good and I have apple care so
you know I'm gonna go show Natalie
oh are you still wanting to use my
iPhone 13 plus just nervous hey you have
every right to be nervous uh do you have
AppleCare nope so that does increase the
stakes a little bit
okay
[Music]
hey Jordan
um so I also don't have any protection
whatsoever the the fate of this phone is
in Ren's hands right now I just bought
this thing and so I'm trusting this this
plastic duck holder there's a lot of
pressure on my shoulder wrist fingers
right now chances are your cell phone is
one of the most expensive items you own
and I'm now holding other people's Souls
I am being so careful right now so
delicate the magnets are a great idea
but it is incredibly precarious
I somehow feel like I'm holding more
money than a red camera I know I'm not
but it feels like I am but that was just
filming at 4K 60. the plan here is to
shoot 240 FPS slo-mo this is a Snyder
camera after all so I think now we
should test it with the pinata in
slow-mo so we came up with the idea to
fill pinatas with Nerf darts or random
debris that looks cool in slow motion
flying outwards so the test is whether
or not this sword this is actually my
personal sword from high school can
actually cut through the pinata this is
a dry run for whether or not this is a
feasible thing because maybe it works
well but doesn't look good I'm not so
worried about shopping through I'm just
worried about what I might do when it's
the blades back in my hands again
these are bongo ties because they look
like bongo drums but it's rubber so it
should grip boom there we go that'll
work
oh I mean it's it's saved it
I'm not gonna do that with it anyway so
this is just like an airbag it's just to
save you in the event of an accident
all right I think we're good to go how
are you feeling about this Nico you
ready
and three two one action
you know it's not bad didn't make it all
the way through I didn't I thought this
would happen Nico just flip it around
and slice it one more time
okay ready and three two one action
I'm so sick yes just took two tries one
would have been nice
look at this I'm proud of this please
holy I mean as a proof of concept it
totally works I think we have most of
the ingredients we need except now we
actually need a subject you know Nico's
cool and all but we need someone who
knows how to use a sword and look cool
doing so and I only know one person
of course Dee's got a whole YouTube
channel where he does a bunch of stuff
it made complete
it's actually my first custom sword I
had built so I designed everything it is
a folded 1095 high carbon steel blade oh
my goodness what's really cool about the
sword is that I have three custom
folders cut into it which reduce the
weight and if you look at the back of
the top half of the blade they basically
cut it into a diamond shape so that has
less resistance when you cut through
things and it also reduces the weight on
the top of the blade so the balance is
like a lot nicer so it's really fast
sore this thing can take off ahead oh
yeah I honestly The Sword in action now
so we had D come in we had to get a
whole bunch more pinatas we filled them
with all sorts of like dust and paint
and things and eggs I really want to do
one where it's uh just four of them in a
row and you're just trying to get from
point A to point B and I'm just gonna
follow you sideways so the purpose of
this shot is to actually replicate the
original shot from 300. so D for this
obviously I'm gonna need you to do the
coolest slices possible but also keep in
mind you got to look cool between the
slices okay I know that'll be easy for
you I'm not worried
the United States dude I went my whole
life for this I'm so excited man this is
like actually working let's start off as
just like this random idea that I was
like wait I think we could do it and
here we are in the middle of the street
making it happen that's what filmmaking
is about okay everything is rolling okay
are you guys ready
and three
two
one
action
all right
[Music]
this is
[Music]
wow hold on I gotta get a picture of
that pose
cool all right cut
oh my God
that was a surprise to everyone I think
I was not expecting that I was like I
just have to cut through the smokes
one last cut wow that was that was nuts
you know what let's break a few more
pinatas let's get some more shots three
two one action
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
I broke the mace that's broken
I'm done you got it we're good that was
awesome all right cut
heck yeah that was awesome where can we
find you D well if you like sword stuff
I have a sword Channel service arms and
I also do so the note Channel sometimes
he goes in videos sometimes other people
are videos the last video we did was uh
we shot a katana with a bunch of guns to
see if it split the bullets so if you
want to see a katana get shot to Pieces
by guns head on over to that channel
check it out thanks for having me it was
really fun thanks a lot you can killed
it thanks man like literally you killed
them
it worked it totally worked and I'm so
excited it's I'm so proud that this
thing actually worked but you may have
noticed a little bit in shakiness in
these shots you know they are not
perfect so how can we actually make this
better because I think one of the most
important aspects of any sort of
creative Endeavor it's the idea of
reflection you have to reflect upon what
worked and how you can make it better
because that's how you get better so
what did I learn from this project well
a few things one I think the magnets
were a great idea but it can be improved
upon secure them down a little bit
better maybe have some sort of latch
that actually holds the phone as like a
bit of a safety thing secondly well
having the flexibility to zoom in and
out whenever I want is incredible but
the problem is that I'm still locked
into that framing whatever it is and I
tried actually reframing some of the
shots in post which does work to a
degree but if you lose quality anytime
you have the wider images coming in
because they're super zoomed in so
instead of having everything be aligned
right in the center of frame I can have
stuff be aligned slightly higher alter
the design maybe like rotate this one
upwards like two or three degrees so
that way the overall composition is
better the last thing is the
misalignment in the images caused by the
optical image stabilization so I
actually ended up having to go through
and add hundreds of keyframes moving the
position of each layer so that when we
did reframe it matched up that required
a lot of manual work the problem is that
there's no way to turn that off unless
you physically hack your phone to do so
the image stabilization uses magnets to
like move the actual sensor so if you
take a magnet and literally put it on
the other side of your phone you will
lock the sensor into place preventing it
from moving if I did that for each of
the phones we wouldn't have had that
sort of wobbly image look and I could
have set the framing to be Rock Solid
for the entire shot that would have
reduced so much work those are things I
learned by doing you know that's part of
the design process and that's why I
think reflection is so important to any
sort of thing that you make and honestly
those are just like the first three
things I can think of there's probably a
million different ideas that could
improve this rig if you have any of
those leave a comment down below I'll be
reading through them and of course I'm
going to be doing more of these kind of
builds in the future so make sure you
subscribe to see those we've got Nerf
Drone 2.0 coming at some point soon
huh triple smush
piano purple smudge panel
can I can you choose lenses first piano
oh
you ready
and
go oh hey it actually all worked totally
did work that is so bizarre
[Music]